hi und willkommen zu vlogm Tag 14 wir
befinden uns gerade auf dem Weg nach
Basel von zermat um dort dann mit dem
Flugzeug nach Berlin zurückzufliegen und
gestern war ich ganz fleißig und habe
und Snacks für die Fahrt gekauft
wirklich alles was ich im Supermarkt
gefunden habe die Auswahl sah so gut aus
ich hätte am liebsten alles mitgenommen
ich weiß nicht ob das normal ist für
Schweizer Supermärkte ich war bei KOB C
OOP Hammer ze von ze und das erste was
wir heute testen sind zweifelpaprika ich
habe da so meine Zweifel ob sie gut sein
werden aber let's try it sie sind mit
Schweizer alpensalz und Rapsöl ich weiß
nicht was das für ein Geschmack sein
soll ehrlich gesagt Salz und Rapsöl und
das eine kleine
Paprika die sehen nach ganz normalen
Paprikachips aus sie riechen auch nach
ganz normalen
Paprikachips Standard leckere
paprikaips
ze von ze schmecken so wie sie schmecken
sollen als nächsten Snack haben wir die
aperis Sticks Randen mit einem Hauch
merretig ich weiß nicht was Randen sind
ich glaube es ist rote Bette weil hier
das sieht nach rote Bee aus und
irgendwie irgendwie ist da mit Kartoffel
knusprig gebacken mildgesalzen mit
Kartoffelmehl salzgebcksticks mit
Kartoffeln und Rande klingt auch
wunderbar h GU mal wie die
aussehen also die sehen nach Plastik
aus oh mein Gott die lecker die
schmecken ein bisschen wie diese
brotsticks die man beim Italiener
bekommt aber dann mit diesem
hauchgeschmack von Randen und dieses
Kartoffelmehl also es ist richtig
richtig cool und sieht halt auch voll
cool aus ne damit kann man voll die
lustigen Sachen so basteln auch
geschmacklich würde ich sagen von
[Musik]
ze und wieder Zug und ich fah wieder
rückwärts das gibt doch nicht rückwärts
die fals cheidung ich die falung ich
kein problemar angenehmer dann kann ich
immer alles wasort angucken ein Snack
ne hast du Bock auf ein weiteren Snack
gut dann snacken wir jetzt noch was wir
haben nämlich einiges mein Sack ist voll
ich habe für dich die
mathornkekse doch ein W ich probieren
wollen ein mathornkeks
ne gucken ob das so schön ist wie das
Bild so die sehen genauso aus wie ist
das nicht süß oh mein Gott das ist ein
ganz dünner
Keks mit ganz viel Schokolade drauf
probier mal
hallo probiert den
[Musik]
Keks
verpasst den heftigsten Ausblick
und WoW Butterkeks trifft hoblerone
schmeckt fantastisch können die Basics
einfach die Schweizer der Hammer
unser nächster
Snack also mich erinnert das an ein
Weckmann wie
aussieht wie so ein Pumper der da so was
willst du bisschen irgendwieiert bergin
Türsteher kommst du nicht rein das ist
ein
bioritima/itt ometo die Pasta Bio
Pasta ja ich sag dazu weg
da hat er auch kleine
rosinugen su und probieren wir
mal schmeckt wie typischer
g das ist was es schmeckt wie ein
weniger Süßes Milchbrötchen und trocken
aber ich habe auch gestern schon gekauft
ja wir probieren noch was wie aussieht
wahscheinlich also wenn ich das mit
einer Zugfahrt von Berlin nach Köln
Vergleiche gibt ja mehr zu gucken da
dass hier Menschen einfach so leben und
für die das völlig normal ist ne das ist
so krassusst D 1995 das Wort krass nur
auswahstand für das Jugendwort des
Jahres Jugendliche aus ganz Deutschland
können in diesem Jahr das Jugendwort des
Jahres 1995 wählen folgende Wörter
stehen zur Auswahl krass ist krass noch
cool wahrscheinlich nicht ne Betty Bossi
eine feinste Auswahl an verschiedensten
Keksen Pralinen und
Gebäcken oh die sehen so krass
aus so okay
also Nüsse in
Karamel dann noch die
hier die sind mit mus gefüllt auch so
ganz zuckrig drin die probieren wir auch
noch einfach so gelb gefüllt sist du
das das ist so eine Zitronencreme ja
irgendwie habe ich mir alles bisschen
knuspriger vorgestellt aber das ist
alles so eine kuchige Konsistenz
m das ist lecker eigentlich müsste man
Kaffee oder Tee dazu trinken ja schmeck
alles ganz
okay ist alles nicht so krass
wahrscheinlich ist das aber wenn jetzt
Schweizer das sehen dann denken die so
sorry du hast da übelst das OM Gebäck
gekauft das kauft keiner
hier B du bereit für den nächsten
Snack
ich habe davon noch nie gehört kennst du
die
nee das rieet nach
käsefuß du wirst es lieben
M 10 von ze sehr sehr lecker hi wir sind
in Basel wir haben es doch noch nach
Basel geschafft für eine Stunde sind wir
hier und wir fahren jetzt eigentlich
schon auch zum Flughafen und dann zurück
nach Berlin zu fahren
aber zum Glück haben wir noch einen Sack
voller Snacks wir haben es geschafft wir
haben es geschafft der Flughafen ist
super süß ganz klein sieht irgendwie aus
oder wir gehen jetzt erstmal unsere
Koffer ab und dann müssen wir aber noch
zwei Stunden warten weil unser Flug erst
um 19 Uhr geht und wir jetzt schon da
sind aber ich denke mal dann werden wir
heute den Abend hier verbringen ne let's
go Berlin 19 Uhr da sind wir doch und
süß GLB das sind alle Flüge die hier
abgehen in Berlin wechselt das die ganze
Zeit durch und so hier siehst du es
trotzdem sind es vier Flüge in der
Stunde ist Halle 3 sogar hier kann man
Glühwein kaufen oh m ich glaub Basel ist
voll die Weihnachtsstadt
gewesen so jetzt muss ich aber erstmal
ein paar Snacks die ich für Annie
mitgebracht habe svenir haben wir
natürlich auch mitgenommen das muss ich
jetzt ganz kurz hier einmal Umpacken ja
da ist noch
Platz an die Schweizer Veganer
Schokolade mitgebracht an ist nämlich
vollblutveganerin und die wird sich
freuen über die ganzen vegan
Sachen aus der Schweiz hier
z.B die mache ich jetzt nicht auf die
schenke ich anni vegane lindschokolade
die ganz anders aussieht als die bei uns
in Deutschland oder die sieht doch
richtig cool sogar wir sind an unserem
Platz und wir warten aufs Boarding aber
ich habe noch ein paar Snacks die ich
testen möchte das ist jetzt kein
typisches Schweizer Snack Ding
aber
medol Datteln die haben gerade total den
krassen Hype auf
tiktok oder war
el oh mein Gott schmecken e nach Karamel
wie kann Dattel so lecker
sein keine Ahnung was das sein soll
vegane schokoladenkonfüerie mit
gerösteten Mandelsplittern und
mandeldrink bei den meisten Sachen habe
ich mal das Gefühl man kennt es dann
irgendwie aus Deutschland den
Vergleich aber ich habe keine Ahnung was
das sein soll so mit vanillen und
so oh mein Gott das ist lecker schmeckt
überhaupt nicht
vegan oh mein Gott ze von ze mein Stück
Glück davor hatte ich Angst dass ich
Sachen finde die ich richtig lecker
finde und dann habe ich nicht mehr davon
gekauft oh das ist voll lecker es geht
eigentlich um Schweizer Snacks aber das
habe ich in Italien die ganze Zeit
gesehen und in Italien waren die
Packungen aber zu groß und das ist jetzt
so eine geile kleine Packung und ich
habe es glaube ich noch nie gegessen ich
kann mich auf jeden Fall nicht dran
erinnern pannetone
na hast du l da einmal reinzubeißen
sieht irgendwie aus wie so ein riesen
Muffin
[Musik]
ne schmeckt wie so ein Rosinenbrötchen
das habe ich irgendwie gar nicht
erwartet schmeckt wie ein chrisstollen
ohne Puderzucker in einem fluffigen
Milchbrötchen aber keine Sorge wir sind
noch nicht
durch oh das habe ich dir noch
mitgebracht Fake tublerone biteschön
Fake tuerunne und das war hier auf
diesem weihnachtshaufen drauf Biber
Bibers daerbackwarere mit 39%
Mandelfüllung auf dieser dauerbackwarere
mit Mandelfüllung ist aber ein Lama
hebkuchen mit Mandelfüllung und diesem
Bild vorne drauf ich weiß nicht warum
das in der weihnachtsabteilung
[Musik]
war schmeckt schlecht das lebk schmeckt
überhaupt lecker und dann schmeckt das
mandelzeug mandelzeug schmeckt gar nicht
nachzip Geschmack erwartet dann gibt das
letzte für heute Kaugummi mit
Zimtgeschmack geil ich habe nur so
Bigpack gefunden jetzt wenn mir das
nicht schmeckt ärgere ich mich du musst
auch kaugumi mit Dings probieren ne ist
du die Schokolade ja wie schmeckt Fake
Toblerone wie originalblerone
echt viicht wie bei anderen Sachen wo
sie eigentlich auch die Produzenten sind
guck mal wie das zimugumi aussieht
das ist lecker der schmeckt wie Big
Red
scharf das ist gut aber super scharf
aber geil zimtig mein Gesicht sieht
vielleicht nicht danach aus aber es ist
richtig geil ich habe noch nie so ein
intensiven Zimtgeschmack im Mund gehabt
ja also wir fliegen jetzt gleich los da
hinten fängt schon Boarding an und dann
geht's nach Berlin und wir sehen uns
wieder morgen zu vlogmas Tag 14 ich
freue mich morgen passiert was
krasses mhm bleibt gespannt